the field of bioinformatics has evolved
and faces a challenge of big complex
data that is readily available yet hard
to process and integrate often making it
difficult to extract meaningful
information from this valuable resource
this resource connects biologists
clinicians and data scientists that have
to work together to move forward
high-quality education is at the center
of this issue and this is critical
because at the center of data generation
data analysis and decision-making extend
people that need to have a common
understanding of the logic of data
analysis in the lab biologists need to
know in what way to improve data
collection and what kind of data is
needed to answer critical research
questions in a reliable way
they need to know about testing
hypotheses and even training in machine
learning models by informaticians are
working on new methods to improve how
these heterogeneous data sets can be
integrated but they need to know the
biology behind the data and understand
how the analysis results might be used
and at the end of the day scientists
rely on the analysis results for
decision making they need to know what
can be trusted where are we to expect
batch effects or even model overfitting
and lack of representation that's why we
need better training and bioinformatics
to learn biology as a data science but
the word data science or bioinformatics
can be well uncomfortable or even scary
math statistics and computer science are
essential for any kinds of
bioinformatics while that is true we
believe that at some level
bioinformatics can be accessible to all
even those that do not have the time to
learn how to code or solve math problems
even for biology majors and clinicians
easy enough and at the same time
practical and truly informative for
anyone that's why when we think of these
educational challenges we want to make
sure that we have a personalized
experience for different
students solutions to help tackle to
adopt the materials without taking up
too much of their time and precious
resources data to help administration
measure efficiencies and outcomes of the
program and finally opportunities to
translate this training into a real
research experience let me share with
you how we are addressing these
challenges in bioinformatics education
today over the past several years we
have participated in a number of
programs at university campuses around
the world working with faculty
researchers and students to build a
basic collection of six modules that
cover the important data types methods
and applications and bioinformatics
these include introduction to
bioinformatics genomics transcriptomics
epigenomics metagenomics and an
introduction to machine learning these
modules are available through our online
portal and help establish a good
foundation that one can build upon with
practical assignments and projects each
module is an online learning experience
that is built with easy navigation tools
discussion forums glossary and other
tools to make the lessons delivery
effortless the content has some
theoretical background and interesting
insights but the most important part is
that each module is supported by
practical exercises each lesson will
prepare the participant to analyze a
real data set using the T bio info
analytical platform that makes complex
bioinformatics analyses simple visual
and interactive all the major data types
like next-generation sequencing mass
spectroscopy structural biology and even
a fit of typic data like images can be
analyzed on the platform and integrated
for a systems biology view of any
experiment
the data outputs are easily analyzed
using an intuitive interface and guided
by advanced visual tools the data is
also linked back to biology using our
interactive viewers and standardized
outputs we call this unique program Onix
logic
it requires no background in coding
there are no installations dependencies
or troubleshooting our scripts and
finding libraries the program is
streamlined visual and interactive and
finally it is practical and project
oriented built to provide hands-on
experience with real data sets and
solutions to common scientific
challenges the infrastructure has many
components integrated into a high
performance type of technology hosted
jointly by Pine biotech and the tower
bioinformatics Research Center at the
University of Haifa in Israel the
Research Centre was established by
scientists with a deep knowledge and
understanding of cutting-edge
technologies methods and innovative
approaches to research and education at
the core of the rmx logic program are
projects that are based on published
experiments with associated data that
resulted in impactful publications in
taught scientific journals our team
extracts the data and methods that were
described providing the background of
the study and offering a series of
practical exercises that allows anyone
to repeat an almost identical process as
they learn about the challenges and how
to overcome them using various bi
informatics techniques as a result new
questions that come up from this
experience can be developed into an
independent novel project with new data
and even modifications to the methods
used
these projects include a variety of
topics in epigenetics human health
agriculture biology immunology precision
medicine and others these practical
exercises and exposure to data driven
discovery using real research data
encourage critical thinking provide a
deep understanding of data specific
challenges and showcase how various
methods of analysis are applied in
real-world situations
results from student projects are often
novel and important in their own way
providing bioinformatics support to
faculty led research enhancing
mentorship developing interdisciplinary
collaboration and offering a way for
students to advance their interests in
research faculty and administration will
find the implementation of this program
to be more simple than it might seem we
offer detailed data on participant
activity including time spent and
modules and quizzes advanced grading
tools practical analysis evaluation and
a point system that offers insights into
group dynamics this overview can be
expanded by a deeper dive into each
student's progress and timeline of
activity for faculty we offer a modular
system that allows them to easily
integrate their available modules and
projects into an existing class making
projects relevant to the other topics
cover and to their own research
interests the online modules can be
combined together expanded or reduced
depending on the schedule and time
commitment that is required our mix
logic is the only program that offers
cutting edge technology curated datasets
plug-and-play curriculum elements and
support for easy implementation and
effective use as a result a non-violent
ition can teach learn and use
bioinformatics in a meaningful way and
interact with computational biologists
to get better results and insights from
big onyx
it